the electric knife fish or electric eel
to its friends has one of the most
shocking talents in the animal kingdom
literally used to sense an attack prey
the electric eels ability to generate
store and release jolts from within its
body has fascinated scientists for
centuries and now they're mimicking it
on a quest to create a flexible bio
battery which could power all kinds of
futuristic tech to wear on our bodies
and even inside our bodies
to make an electric eel inspired battery
the first thing to understand is how the
Eels do it enter specialized cells
called electrocytes these cells have
membranes that allow certain charged
ions to pass through leaving the cell in
a neutral state when it's resting when
the eel is ready to strike channels on
one side of the cell open and positive
ions rush in generating a current and
zap it's curtains for the unsuspecting
prey
each electro site only produces around
150 millivolts but large eels can have
thousands of them packed together like a
battery using some clever nervous system
timing they're able to activate them all
simultaneously making for a hefty shock
scientists based at the University of
Freiburg in Switzerland took inspiration
from this process to create an
artificial electric organ they used
blobs of hydrogel to mimic each part of
the electro site yellow and green blobs
act as the selectively permeable
membranes red and blue blobs contain
different levels of the ions just like
the eel ions rush across these membranes
to generate a current each group of four
blobs can produce about the same voltage
as an electric eels electro site also
like the eel scientists wanted to stack
their artificial cells up to increase
the voltage but how do you do that one
answer printing when laid on top of each
other
these two sheets laden with hydrogel
blobs form one long line of repeating
units enough to generate about a hundred
volts
now there's one more thing the eel fires
all of its electro sites simultaneously
to get maximum voltage and the
scientists need to do the same to get
that high voltage all of the gels need
to contact at the same time the sheets
made it faster but for truly
simultaneous connections the researchers
came up with another idea folding this
allowed all the bio gel blobs to touch
each other almost simultaneously the eel
can recharge its battery by illogically
within its body whereas right now the
artificial battery needs to be connected
up to a power source researchers want to
use their battery to power things like
contact lenses with integrated displays
or biological sensors or even wearable
tech so the hope is that their battery
to will one day be recharged
biologically after all if the eel can do
it why can't we right
you